- Good morning believe nation,
today's message is, "Do one thing."
Over to you Robert Rodriguez.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
♫ I wake up every morning ♫
- There's this book called, The One Thing,
have you ever seen that?
It says you should just do one thing.
And I go, "Well, I shouldn't
even bother reading that.
"That doesn't apply to me."
But then I thought about it.
It's like, "Well I do one thing,
"I live a creative life."
Everything you do you
apply a creativity to it.
Whether it's the way
you meet with a friend
and you make them dinner or
you do stuff with your kids.
And then when you go, and
you're working on an idea
and you're doing music as the same time
while you're on the set.
You're never in a block because
you're always actually in a flow.
If you don't live your life creatively
and then you set aside some time at night
to go write your novel,
you're going to get a block
because you're not in the flow.
But if you apply creativity
to everything in your life,
everything is available to you.
To where suddenly you can paint.
You'll see paintings
I did with the actors.
Even though they are very
creative in the acting world,
they didn't think they could paint.
So I made them paint and then
they saw they were able to
because when you are in a creative flow
you can do just about anything.
So it's all about living a creative life
to where you can't
possibly ever get blocked
because you're always,
"Okay, I have an idea for writing
"so I'm going to go cook something"
Which is art you can eat.
You know, and you're serving
it and you're eating it,
and consuming it and you're creating.
And you go back and you do that.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah, there's no
structured boxes around it.
It's like a lifestyle.
- There's no delineation
between work and play.
It's all play.
- This is why it's so important
to find your one word.
Because it's not just about
doing one thing, one task,
it's about living one way.
Your way, on purpose and
knowing what that is.
So if I look at this clip as an example,
Robert's one word is
likely creative, right?
He wants to be creative.
He wants to live in a creative way.
It's not just doing one task all day long,
but doing creative work all day long.
That's where he comes alive.
And if you try to put Robert in a room
with no doors and no windows,
and just lock him in there in a cell
and told him what to do, he would die.
If you starved all the
creativity out of him
and forced him to do
something he would hate it.
He would struggle,
nobody would know who he was.
And that's most people.
Most people have no idea who they are,
and are stuck in a box
that somebody else has made for them,
and they don't know how to get out.
They don't know what their one word is.
They don't know how to break free.
They don't know how to
design a life on purpose.
It's why it's so important to understand
what the one word is for you,
that now you can create
something and design it.
A life and a business
around what you want to do.
So lets look at creativity,
let's look at Robert a little bit more.
All the people that he
surrounds himself with
should be people who help
him be more creative.
All the content that he
consumes on a daily basis,
I don't know what his habits are.
Is he reading books?
Is he watching YouTube videos?
Is he checking out the news?
Is he going to theaters?
Is he going to the movies?
The content that he consumes
should make him feel more creative.
His daily habits and rituals,
whatever that looks like,
whether it's meditation,
or doing yoga, or watching
some YouTube videos,
watching Entspresso in the morning,
those things should be designed
to help him be more creative.
And so once you understand
what the one word is for you,
what the one way is for you,
when you figure that out,
then you look at your life.
You look at what your typical
weekly schedule looks like.
You look at the things
that you are consuming
on a daily basis.
You look at the people that
you're hanging around with constantly.
And how many of those people,
activities and things,
help that one way, help that
one word come out of you.
And for a lot of people at the start
it's a really sobering experience.
For a lot of people,
like if you're unhappy with your life,
if you feel like you have a huge ceiling
and you're not anywhere close
to reaching your potential
it's because a lot of the
people, things, and habits
that you have on a daily
basis are not coming out.
They're suppressing you.
They're keeping you in your box,
and it starts because you don't
even have the self awareness
to know what your one word is.
You don't have the self awareness to know
what the one thing is
that you should be doing.
What the one way of living
is and you should be living.
So figure it out.
Then do an audit of your life,
and the habits, and the
things that are around you.
Say, "Does this help me believe more,
or create more, or care more?"
It's the unlock.
It gives you certainty.
It give you clarity.
It gives you power,
and it lets you do amazing things.
So the question to think today is,
I'm curious what is the one
way that you want to live.
What is the one word core value for you,
and once you figure that out,
what's one thing that you
need to start changing.
What's the one thing in your
life that does not support you
being creative, or
believing, or caring more,
and you need to eliminate
that from your life.
Super curious to find out.
Leave it down in the comments below,
and we'll join in discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shot out to Peter Oji,
Peter thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going